hey gun owner Brian here and guess what
we are now on Google+
yes I'm leaving a space here for you to
applaud because I'm alone in my office I
can't hear you and you're done
applauding yes this is exciting I'm on
Google+ ah no idea why I'm on Google+
I'm already on MySpace and Twitter and
Friendster and and Tumblr and flub flub
and give gab I'm all over the place even
have a pen pal in Micronesia
he's an 11 year old boy named tui so
quick shout out to tui hey to e he won't
see this cuz his computer was stolen by
the rival village talk about that later
actually people never discuss it yet the
point is this
I'm now on Google+ I'm very excited and
I want to do something special for my
first week on Google+ so I'm gonna
feature an entire week of judgmental
animals that's right
animals with judgmental expressions this
is my way of proving that the internet
is not a huge waste of time so enjoy
judgmental animals thanks for having me
on Google+ and I'll see you around the
interweb
[Music]